we have a brand new agent in valorant
and all I have to say is thank you Mr
John Riot say goodbye to the dead
Central mother and hello to a deadlock
are her abilities as overpowered as they
look when it comes to deadlock not
everything may be what it seems
[Music]
so this episode is all about valorent
and before we get into deadlock I have
some very exciting news to share my
Premiere and extremely real Esports
organization Elizabeth Sports is not
making any changes to our lineup we are
sticking with our core but in order to
afford these salaries I decided to start
a business in order to keep up with the
moist mobiles and disguise of the scene
this is where our friends at Shopify
come in I'm a team owner not a tech kid
and they're all-in-one Commerce platform
makes it super easy for anyone to jump
in and start a business regardless of
their technical or experience level they
simplify everything you need in order to
grow and manage that dream business
you've always wanted Shopify Powers
millions of businesses across 175
countries including the merch for your
favorite orgs we actually use it for our
own merge at the score Esports and
hopefully Elizabeth Sports will be a
successful one day they even have
Shopify learn to teach me business
skills for Elizabeth Sports so I can
handle all of my elizabethness and get
it yeah I'm not even sorry thanks to
Shopify for sponsoring this video for a
free trial head to shopify.com to score
Esports using the link below I'm back
baby I know it's been a while since I've
been on donami but I just had to stop by
and tell you all about valerian's newest
agent deadlock deadlock was released in
the 7.0 version update of valorant she
is a sentinel so she joins the ranks of
killjoy Cipher and Sage Liz what about
chamber he's a sentinel too yeah I don't
care about the Frenchman at all okay he
could be deleted from the game and I
could not care less deadlock comes at a
perfect time because frankly The
Sentinel meta has not been fun or
engaging in any way chamber was a must
pick and then he got nerfed to the
heaven so nobody picks him anymore Sage
keeps getting Nerfs and more expensive
economy wise so nobody picks her anymore
killjoy and Cipher are your best picks
as Sentinels and I mean this with my
entire former KJ main heart they are so
so so so so so so boring Sentinels were
not actionary KJ's turret moved more
than her some rounds this is where
deadlock comes in like other Sentinels
she does have abilities that I would
call in my theater days a park can bark
which basically means you just let them
stand there and do their thing so
basically she has one ability that fits
that description and that is her Sonic
sensor basically press Q to plant this
device on a wall and if someone makes
noise while going by AKA they don't
shift walk it will go off and concuss
them if you reload it will go off you
can hear it make a wub wub sound as you
walk by however but all of our other
utility is very much a use it or lose it
type beat her C ability is a gravnet
where you toss a grenade that if it
catches enemies within its radius forces
them to crouch and move slowly her
signature ability AKA her e is a barrier
mesh which blocks any player movement
let me be clear and I promise you will
thank me later you can shoot through it
you can throw things through it you
cannot walk through it I just saved you
from being chewed out in team chat
you're welcome and her ultimate ability
is the most frustrating thing I've
encountered in this game and I am a
survivor of the chamber meta when she's
not screaming the longest voice line in
the game she throws the ability that
caches and cocoons the first enemy it
sees and just pulls them along helpless
unless an ally frees them again let me
help you out and save you the
embarrassment that I suffered
nothing there
you should open the land I found out the
hard way that it doesn't go through
walls I swore after watching that demo
it did but uh no it does not it kind of
bounces off walls though like a like a
one bounce sober Dart the alt is
incredibly precise though I had a
co-worker stand in a variety of rot
spots and sometimes it took a couple of
tries to get him cocooned the Nano
thingies that show up God bless Ellie
when he tries to figure out how they act
so those are her abilities very reliant
on team coordination and set play you
see when I say that she makes the agent
pool of Sentinels less boring that does
not automatically mean that she is a
high quality agent sort of like how
video games can have really exciting
action but a terrible story like
BioShock Infinite be honest I upset you
back to the point at hand again the
opinions depend on the person you ask
about the agent Chet said that this is
the best agent release since Gekko for
context this has been the only agent
released since Gekko it wins by default
kind of like saying that I'm the best
daughter in my family I am the only
daughter lothar said that she is Turbo
week listing a plethora of reasons as to
why he thinks so including a lack of a
recharging signature ability and weak
old some think that she is sort of in
the Goldilocks zone of being just fine
situational not overtuned and not meta
defining I asked bcj to give me his
thoughts on stream and this is what he
had to say deadlock is the new Sentinel
added in valorant and I've got a few
tips for you to go valorant pro first
thing about deadlock that she's really
good about is she's kind of like a
pseudo Sage she her wallability can
block off multiple entrances and it
takes a lot of bullets so you can
actually get away with using it in post
plan using it to keep areas locked down
uh kind of like an offensive ability or
tool the second thing that's really good
about uh deadlock is that she gets
Universal trips but the the caveat to
that is that um the trips can only be
activated from sound so if people shift
work around the trips don't do anything
he turned his desktop audio down for me
so I need everyone in the comment
section to say thank you Brendan happy
early birthday I asked my long lost twin
baby Bae about his thoughts in the agent
and while he admitted he didn't have a
lot of experience with the agent the
defensive potential is there deadlock
seems like a really good Agent on
defense
but I don't know how it's going to be
used on attack yet I feel like people
need to figure that out it doesn't seem
as strong on attacking because on
defense my opinion is we do this song
and dance almost every single time an
agent is released we go to either
extreme of it's good or it's terrible or
whatever and then some time passes then
we realize that like every other agent
in the game depends on who you are as a
player and the team you are a part of
y'all remember when Harbor came out all
y'all said that he was super weak and
not up to par then you all saw the light
and realized his success depends on the
map and the comp almost like that is the
point of the game shocking I know teams
and audiences like to see safe tried and
true comps we question non-meta picks
and I am guilty of this I heard about
paper Rex's something on Reina and sort
of chuckled and well
oh all the info
sends the dog in a few of them stunned
something
wow
something is insane as Ryan are Unbound
actually insane
in our most recent tier one competition
Masters Tokyo where something was unable
to play Reina was hardly chosen with a
pick rate of one percent and you can
think bustio for that and something only
plays Reyna on bind it is something
specific to that team that map and that
comp I'm not saying Chet or lothar have
to wake up and see that deadlock is the
best agent in the game I don't really
think I am in a position to tell Chet or
lothar anything at the end of the day
deadlock might just be okay and that is
okay it might be nice for a change to
have something balanced right out of the
box we just have to see how she is her
wall is insane her grenade is her Sonic
sensor my lurking self has no problem
just walking by and her ultimate is an
Anchor's worst nightmare
but those are just my opinions and I
would love to hear yours down in the
comment section below regardless I hope
you have fun playing her and best of
luck trying to get your teammates to get
you out of that ultimate ability
good luck have fun babes
forbidden door two was last Sunday I
almost cried I cried a lot of things
you're getting the I just I love
wrestling Danny I love wrestling Kenny
Omega versus will Osprey was so cool
there's one wrestler Brian Danielson who
wrestled a match with a broken forearm
like like snapped in half broken forearm
wrestling's so cool I love wrestling